numéro 1 le chiffon me alors pierre
feuille ciseaux vous connaissez tous
ciseaux baffles bat pierre et pierre bat
ciseaux mais quel est l'équilibré de
nash de ce jeu alors ça paraît pas
évident a priori puisque peu importe ce
que vous faites
l'autre pour avoir une stratégie qui
vous fera perdre et bien l'astuce de
vollmann qui fut reprise ensuite par
nage flux de considérer des stratégies
dites mixtes ou randomisés typiquement
vous allez décider de jouer au hasard
pierre feuille ciseaux et dès lors
sachant que vous jouez aléatoire -
détroit votre adversaire n'aura pas de
stratégie qui vous fera perdre en
moyenne
or en pratique nous les humains on n'est
quand même pas très bon pour jouer
aléatoirement et du coup les
compétitions internationales de chifoumi
c'est bon pas mal de hasard mais pas que
et d'ailleurs le new york times a sorti
une intelligence artificielle pour jouer
aux chiffres me apparemment a tendance à
battre pas mal d'humains enfin je ne
peux pas vous laisser sans vous parler
ou moins rapidement du chiffre fourni
plus de chifoumi plus plus archifaux me
plus j'entend pierre feuille ciseaux et
puis alors si vous jouez au chifoumi
plus je vous déconseille très fortement
de jouer pierre je crois que vous voulez
jouer pierre à la place jouée puis et
oui parce que le puits fait toujours au
moins aussi bien que la pierre comme la
pierre le puits bas le ciseau et perd
contre la feuille mais en plus le puits
bas la pierre en fait l'équipe de nage
du chiffre me + consiste à jouer
aléatoirement feuille ciseaux ou puis
enfin le chiffon me puce plus c'est
pierre feuille ciseaux les arts spock et
sheldon sur big bang theory on parle
très bien c'est comme ça je vous pose
pas je sais ce que c'est l'unique
équilibre de nashville chifoumi puce
puce c'est de jouer uniformément
aléatoirement pierre feuille ciseaux les
arts ou spock et les avantages du
chiffre me + plus c'est que la
probabilité d'avoir une égalité est
beaucoup plus faible qu'aux chiffres
nuit enfin dernière remarque tout ce que
je viens de raconter ici est en fait
intimement liée au scrutin de commencer
randomisés mais moi je ne vais pas
explicité le lien ici je vous laisse y
réfléchir par vous même numéro deux le
plus grand nombre on ya joué quand on
était gamins chacun dira nombre est le
plus grand nombre gagne mais quel est
l'équilibré de nash de ce jeu je vais y
réfléchir encore une fois bah en fait
y en a pas et il peu importe ce que
l'autre dit vous pourrez toujours dire
nombre plus grand et peu importe ce que
vous dites l'autre pourrez toujours
trouver un nombre encore plus grand
quitte à atteindre dénombre archi méga
super géant en fait le théorème de nash
ne s'applique pas ici parce que
l'ensemble des actions de chacun des
joueurs n'est pas un ensemble fini
chaque joueur peut dire n'importe quel
nombre et il ya un nombre infini de
nombreux numéros 3 le dilemme du
prisonnier
je suis sûr que vous connaissez celui là
alice et bob se font arrêter par la
police
et si l'un balance l'autre alors il
réduit sa peine en particulier peu
importe ce que dit alice
bob a tout intérêt à dénoncer alice
puisqu'il réduit ainsi sa peine et vice
versa en fait l'unique équilibre de nage
de ce jeu est le cas où les deux joueurs
se dénonce mutuellement et ça ça paraît
pas si malin puisqu'il s'en sortent tous
les deux moins bien que s'il était tout
est de rester silencieux sauf que bien
sûr ce cas où tous les deux restent
silencieux n'est pas rationnel puisqu'il
est incompatible avec les intérêts
individuels alors le biais du prisonnier
c'est un cas uniquement à deux joueurs
mais on peut tout à fait le généraliser
à toute notre société
avez vous déjà fraude et en prenant le
métro avez vous déjà jeter des déchets
dans la nature ou avez vous déjà voté
sans avoir lu les programmes des
candidats dans tous ces cas si vous avez
choisi l'action immoral vous êtes
comporté en ce que l'on appelle un
freerider est en partie fait vous avez
joué un équilibre de nash et bien sûr
vous compter sur les autres pour ne pas
jouer cet équilibre d'une hache et pour
s'occuper des biens communs sauf que
bien sûr si chacun se comporte comme
vous si chacun y met sa propre petite
pollution alors les biens communs sont
en grand danger
c'est ce que l'on appelle la tragédie
des biens communs pour éviter la
dégradation des biens communs il nous
faut intervenir dans le jeu et élaborer
un contrat social qui punit les
freeriders que ce soit légalement ou
socialement et oui pour la théorie des
jeux des trucs comme le public chez ming
sont des solutions sociétal au dilemme
du prisonnier numéro 4 le dîner sans
scrupules imaginez vous au restaurant
entre amis avant de commander vous
mettez d'accord pour diviser la note
finale en parts égales plutôt que chacun
paie sa part mais du coup
individuellement vous avez maintenant
intérêt à commander des trucs en
relativement cher puisque la division en
parts égales répartira le prix de votre
truc assez cher entre vos amis mais du
coup si tout le monde fait ça tout le
monde va commander des trucs plus cher
et tout le monde se retrouvera avec une
note finale qui est plus grande que ce
qu'il aurait payé s'il avait commandé
juste ce qu'ils voulaient payer et en
particulier vous allez tous payer plus
que si vous vous étiez mis d'accord
avant de commander que chacun paie sa
part et ça ça explique pourquoi les
restaurants en europe n'aime pas les
factures c'est pareil numéro 5 le duo
paul de cours nous deux entreprises a et
b produisent exactement le même produit
avec le même coût de fabrication il ya
une certaine demande pour le produit
plus le prix est élevé moins il y aura
d'acheteurs potentiels
imaginons pour commencer que les deux
entreprises fusionnent en une entité
c'est en choisissant une certaine
quantité à produire la courbe de la
demande nous dit quel va être le prix de
vente du bien
le profit de l'entreprise c'est sera
alors la quantité qu'il a produite fois
le prix de vente unitaire du bien - le
coût de production du bien et ça ça
correspond à l'ère du rectangle sur le
dessin que voici
supposons maintenant que les entreprises
a et b sont en compétition
alors chacune choisit sa propre
production
là encore à partir des quantités
produites par les deux entreprises
la courbe de la demande nous permet d'en
déduire le prix de vente
et là encore on peut calculer les
profits des deux entreprises ça
correspond aux arts des deux rectangles
que voici
sauf que cette fois chacune des
entreprises choisies sa propre
production pour maximiser ses propres
profits on a là un jeu entre les deux
entreprises et l'équilibré de nash de ce
jeu correspond à une quantité totale
produite plus grande et un prix de
ventes plus faibles et bien cette
analyse de l'économie par antoine
augustin cournot s'est retrouvé au coeur
de nombreuses théories économiques plus
iliad entreprises en compétition
plus il ya abondance des biens produits
un prix faible
al'inverse quand il n'y a pas de vraie
compétition les entreprises peuvent
créer un phénomène de rareté réduisant
la quantité de biens disponibles pour
avoir des prix plus élevés et ce par
bouygues sfr et orange
numéro 6 la moitié de la moyenne des
autres mais
jean est un jeu à 10 personnes chacun
doit annoncer un montant entre 0 et 100
et celui qui annonce un montant qui est
le plus proche de la moitié de la
moyenne de tous les montants annoncés
gagne tous les montants annoncés
supposons que tous les joueurs soient
super intelligent quels montants annonce
auriez vous n'hésitez pas à mettre pause
pour y réfléchir
alors tout le monde va annoncer les
montants entre 0 et 100 du coup la
moitié de la moyenne de tout le monde
est forcément entre 0 et la moitié de
sang entre 0 et 50 et du coup vu que
tous on peut faire ce raisonnement tout
le monde va annoncer quelque chose qui
est entre 0 et 50 et vous voyez ce qu'on
veut avec ce raisonnement si tout le
monde annonce opus 50 on sait que la
moitié de la moyenne de tout le monde
sera au plus 25
donc tout le monde annoncera au plus 25
mais alors la moitié de la moyenne de
tout le monde sera au plus 12 5
donc tout le monde annoncera opus 12,5
et ainsi de suite
in fine et on en vient à la conclusion
étonnante qui suis l'unique équilibre de
nage de ce jeu est le cas où tout le
monde annonce 0 et où personne ne gagne
quoi que ce soit numéro 7 colombes
versus faucon imaginons qu'il valait
mieux céder plutôt que faire la guerre
autrement dit vous pouvez vous comportez
soit comme une colombe soit comme un
faucon sido colombes se rencontrent les
ressources sont partagées et tout va
bien
si un faut qu'on s'attaque à une colombe
alors le faucon vol toutes les
ressources de la combe et du coup on a
une situation gagnant perdant
enfin si deux faucons se rencontrent ils
se font la guerre mutuellement et meurt
tous les deux d'une situation mort moi
ce jeu à deux équilibre évident à savoir
le cas où l'un se comporte comme un
faucon et l'autre se comporte comme une
colombe et oui si l'autre est une
colombe à barra autant être un faucon et
voler ses ressources mais si l'autre est
déjà un faucon vaut mieux éviter de
faire la guerre on va mourir tous les
deux imaginons maintenant que ce jeu
décrivent les interactions entre les
animaux d'une même espèce
autrement dit chaque joueur se comporte
comme un faucon ou comme une colombe
toute sa vie et chaque jour deux animaux
de même espèce se rencontrent et l'issue
de la rencontre sera dictée par le jeu
que l'on vient de décrire la théorie des
jeux dit évolutionnaire c'est-à-dire
appliquer à la dynamique des populations
animales prédit alors que la population
de l'espèce animale en question va
converger vers l'unique équilibre de
nash mixte de ce jeu qui correspond à un
certain
de beaucoup de colombes et de quelques
flocons et oui s'il n'y a quasiment que
des colombes
alors les faucons vont voler toutes
leurs ressources et proliférer mais s'il
ya beaucoup de faucon alors autant être
une colombe et attendre que ces faux
qu'on s'entretue ce type de modèle a
notamment été étudié par le biologiste
john maynard smith en 1973 et depuis de
nombreux biologistes exploite les outils
de nage pour étudier les dynamiques des
populations animales numéro 8 le feu
rouge
reprenons le même chemin avec des
voitures à la place des animaux de
voitures arrivent à une intersection
l'idéal c'est que l'une s'arrête pour
que l'autre passe mais ce qui peut très
bien arriver c'est que les deux voitures
s'arrêtent quelques cas sont un peu
perdus en perdante parce qu'elle perde
tous les deux du temps et le pire cas
c'est bien sûr le cas où les deux
voitures essaient de passer et là
badaboum
on dit que les deux voitures doivent se
coordonner et chaque coordination
possible correspond à un équilibre de
nash le problème c'est maintenant
déterminer quels équilibres de nash va
être jouée en particulier ces deux
équilibre de nash sont injustes pour
l'un des conducteurs est bien pour
résoudre ce problème le prix nobel
d'économie robert harmon l'idée
d'introduire un feu rouge
ce feu rouge envoie un signal coordonnée
aux deux voitures et les deux voitures
vont ensuite jouer l'équipe tonnage
suggéré par le feu rouge on parle alors
d équilibre corrélés est ce qu'il va en
coule avec les équilibres corrélés c'est
que dans certains cas ces équilibres
corrélés permet de faire beaucoup mieux
d'avoir une situation final beaucoup
plus gai en gagnante que le meilleur
équilibre de nash numéro 9
l'ultimatum dans le jeu de l'ultimatum
de joueurs doivent se diviser une somme
disons 1000 euros le premier joueur
appelé leader propose une façon de
diviser la somme est le second joueur le
suiveur accepte ou refuse la proposition
du leader
si le suiveur refuse la proposition du
leader alors les mille euros sont perdus
par les deux joueurs bien ce jeu est un
petit peu plus compliqué que ce qu'on a
vu avant parce que l'ensemble des
actions possibles notamment du suiveur
peut-être sophistiqué typiquement ça
peut être un truc du genre
j'accepte la proposition du leader si et
seulement si me propose au moins
en euros alors le cas où ça c'est la
stratégie du suiveur et où le leader
propose une division 200 euros pour lui
et 800 euros pour le suiveur est alors
un équilibre de nash mais en fait on
encore en équilibre de nage si on
remplace les 800 euros par n'importe
quelle grandeur x la difficulté de ce
jeu vient en partie du fait qu'il y à
une infinité d'équilibré de neige
possibles
il ya toutefois une façon alternative
d'analysé ce jeu une fois que le leader
propose de donner même un euro aux
suiveurs le suiveur a intérêt à accepter
puisque de l'alternative est le cas où
ne gagne rien en fait la difficulté de
ce jeu est la dimension temporal
supposons que le suiveur affirme qu'il
n'acceptera la proposition du leader que
si le leader lui propose au moins 800
euros supposons que le leader lui
propose en fait 50 euros est ce que le
second joueur va persister dans sa
stratégie initiale ou est ce qui va se
dire finalement l'an 50 euros à c'est
mieux que zéro
dans le premier cas on parle d'
équilibre de nage tandis que dans le
second cas on parle d' équilibre parfait
ans où je tout équilibre parfait est un
équilibre de nash mais tout équilibre de
nash n'est pas forcément parfait plus
généralement la dimension temporelle
complique toujours grandement les jeux
surtout lorsque des coopérations sont
initialement mise en place mesut ensuite
révisé parce que les rapports de force
ont changé
on parle alors du problème de
consistance temporal et comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer
cette notion est typiquement clé dans
les modèles à la mesquita numéro 10 le
truel d'alger j et pour finir on va
parler d'un jeu que j'ai trouvé sur le
blog
daly j alice bob et charly sont en duel
en pistolet et qui sont 3 devrait
peut-être plus parler de truelle que
deux duels
bref supposons qu alice et bob soit pas
super excellent avec un pistolet et que
charrie par contre est nickel et touche
toujours sa cible alice a la chance de
tirer un coup en première
ensuite ce sera le tour de bob puis
charlie puis à nouveau à lise puis bob
puis charlie fin à moins que l'un de 3
meur dont quelques uns il peut plus
durer
alice s'élance pour tirer qui doit elle
visée bob charlie est bien pour ce
dernier je vais ne pas vous donner la
réponse
alors bien sûr vous trouver une réponse
partielle sur le blog de j mais je vous
invite à essayer d'écrire une réponse
complète dans les commentaires ci
dessous la nymphe en a parlé d'
équilibre de nash et ses tuyaux nous
demande qu'est ce que j'entends par un
eu fini alors fini si vous avez bien
suivi j'ai défini sa dans cet épisode
qu'est ce que j'entends par jeu en
général et bien je n'entends pas
uniquement les jeux de société ou les
jeux vidéo par jeu de façon très
générale j'entende importe quelle
interaction humaine surtout lorsque les
actions d un affect le bien-être des
autres et c'est encore plus intéressant
quand les actions des uns affecte les
stratégies optimales des autres et ça ça
arrive absolument partout dans notre vie
quotidienne que ce soit en l'économie
je veux enfin échange commercial dans
les jeux de pouvoir en politique ou avec
votre propriétaire votre locataire aux
commerçants que sais-je encore j'espère
d'ailleurs vous avoir donné un aperçu
dans cette vidéo du champ d'application
monstreux de la théorie des jeux
bigard il revient sur la vidéo d'encore
avant la vidéo 12 ans j'avais demandé de
comparer les loteries à un bep de à deux
baies 3 et 3b et nous demandent qu'elle
était du coup la bonne réponse est bien
ce qui est très important avoir enterré
des jeux de façon très générale c'est un
truc sur lequel je reviendrai
j'insisterai longuement dessus plus tard
dans cette série c'est le fait qu' on a
tous des préférences différentes et que
du coup la meilleure stratégie pour l'un
peut ne pas être la meilleure stratégie
pour l'autre en partie tuer on ne peut
pas vraiment définir une préférence
rationnel alors si les actions de 20
noeuds man morgenstern sont violets peut
toujours créer ce qu'on appelle un livre
de contes néerlandais ou une façon
d'extorquer la personne qui a des
préférences qui ne sont pas van maenen
stern et parfois les économistes disent
que en ce sens les préférences qui ne
sont pas venus mène morgenstern sont
irrationnels mais en théorie des jeux
quand on parle en fait de rationalité
sait plus quelles sont les stratégies
que vous avez mises en place pour
pouvoir maximiser votre utilité c'est à
dire arriver autant que possible à
l'issue qui correspondra à votre
préférence mais les préférences en tant
que tel est le
non rien de rationnel il n'est pas plus
rationnelle de préférer le risque que
d'être disons averses au risque alors il
arrive souvent notamment dans des
modèles en finance que ce que l'on
cherche à maximiser c'est plutôt
l'espérance de gain c'est à dire
l'espérance des profits ou l'espérance
monétaire à la moyenne d'argent quelque
chose comme ça mais ça s'est souvent
valable uniquement lorsque il ya la loi
des grands nombres puis peut s'être
appliqué et où à force de miser encore
tous les jours etc
on en vient finalement à avoir gain
cumulé qui correspond à peu près à
l'espérance de gain mais si on arrive
dans des jeux en one shot c'est à dire
des jeux walaja probabilité qu'ils
veulent jouer et ce sera pas répétée du
coup il y aura pas la loi des grands
nombres
à ce moment là il faut agir par rapport
aux risques et notre réaction vis-à-vis
du risque
c'est une réaction qui dépend de nos
préférences vis-à-vis du risque qui est
encore une fois une notion extrêmement
subjective et surtout il n'y a pas de
vérité absolue ou de rationalité avoir
vis-à-vis de quelles sont nos
préférences vis-à-vis du risque et ça
c'est très important pour voir notamment
le fait qu' il est très possible qu'un
autre et des préférences totalement
opposées aux nôtres
ça veut pas dire que ses préférences
sont plus irrationnel que les nôtres ou
vice versa et là je vous renvoie
notamment sur la vidéo que j'ai fait sur
la marche des sciences où j'ai souligné
le fait que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui dépendent d'eux des
fonctions objectif de l'utilité des
préférences des différents individus qui
ne peuvent pas être rationalisée qui ne
sont pas sans que ces histoires de
préférence il n'ya pas des préférences
rationnelle à avoir et malheureusement
je trouvais que la marche des sciences
essayé d'imposer une certaine fonction
d'utilité au d'autres en disant que ses
jt a été scientifiquement alors que
c'est pas le cas les utilités et
préférences individuelles n'ont rien de
scientifique et malheureusement je
crains que mélanger les préférences
subjective
non scientifique à des messages
scientifique risque fortement de
fortement décrédibiliser la science en
particulier typiquement dire qu'il faut
absolument lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique sachant que
quand on dit ça il ya forcément des
concessions sous jacente à faire par
exemple il faut sans doute sacrifier un
petit peu de l'économie pour pouvoir
investir plus de temps sur la lutte
contre le changement climatique
ce genre de trade off n'a rien de
scientifique enfin illusionniste et
faire nous fera la remarque que la vidéo
de la semaine dernière sur l'équilibré
de nash est sorti un jour avant
l'anniversaire de la mort de nash
c'est assez je ne savais pas je m'étais
pas rendu compte de ça et c'est assez
fou qui puisqu'il faut savoir que le 22
mai 2015 donc exactement deux ans jour
pour jour avant la vidéo de la semaine
dernière j'avais sorti une vidéo à
l'époque je faisais des vidéos en
anglais
j'avais sorti une vidéo sur le
torpillage géométrie différentielle où
j'avais parlé longuement du john nash où
j'avais pas là forcément été très
élogieux à son sujet où j'avais un peu
décrit comme un arrogant prétentieux
condescendant qui avait aucun respect
pour ses collègues - brion que son
propre génie réfléchit un peu décrit
comme un [ __ ] et ça c'était le 22 mai
2015 il est mort le lendemain c foot est
très très mal et j'étais assez
embarrassé le fait qu'un vidéo la
semaine dernière soit sorti un jour
avant l'anniversaire de la mort de nacho
que je sache r ça fait un petit peu tir
appel de tout cela facebook
elle espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo la prochaine fois on va parler de
poker est notamment dédiée à qui ont
réussi à battre les humains elle est
bluffé au poker alors je sais que
d'habitude aux sciences et aux ventes
déjà fait une vidéo sur le poker mais la
vidéo de david est sorti en 2015 c'est à
dire qu'à l'epoque là
l'intelligence a refusé n'avait pas
encore battu les humains au poker tout
cas pas au heads up no limit et qui plus
est dans la prochaine vidéo fait avoir
une perspective on peut plus théorie des
jeux et on va parler un petit peu
notamment la stratégie de façon globale
du bluff qui est un truc qui n'apparaît
pas tant que ça finalement dans le poker
limite c'est dont david vous à paris
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
ligue et avait commenté à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas entrer
les futurs épisodes mars le petit port
pour lordon et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois alors la question
que je voulais vous poser à propos de ce
jeu c'est existe-t-il des stratégies qui
permettent de gagner à tous les coups
jouer ici chez vous essayez je vous
donnerai la solution dans une prochaine
vidéo commencer par exemple avec des
positions plus simple que se passe-t-il
si au départ il ya seulement quatre cinq
ou six bateaux n'ai commencé pas
forcément tout de suite avec 20 madonna
la poule en mémorisant ça vous ne
perdrez plus jamais au morpion les seule
chose à retenir c'est que si vous êtes
le 1 vous commencé dans un angle et vous
continuez la ligne
si vous êtes le 2 vous commencé au
centre puis vous bloquez et s'il a
commencé au centre vous jouez dans un
coin et vous bloquez